a new Kingdom Hearts game and Madden NFL
21 are on the way and if you're
wondering why the PS 5 is so huge
we've got answers I'm Cassidy and you've
reached your safe safe for Tuesday June
16 there's a new Kingdom Hearts game
coming this year but before you get
hyped about a sequel it's more of a
spin-off and it's a rhythm game Kingdom
Hearts melody of memory is a rhythm
based game set to some of the greatest
hits of the series the new trailer shows
the main trio of Sora Donald and Goofy
running along a track and fighting
Heartless to the rhythm of the songs we
also see Sora running alongside Riku and
Roxas level seen include destiny islands
Aruba Olympus and the Keyblade graveyard
the whole thing seems pretty similar to
theater than Final Fantasy it's coming
Xbox one ps4 on switch later this year
and I'm pretty excited about it I love
those songs and I can't wait to play
there's been a question on my mind since
the ps5 reveal event and no it's not
what is buck Snacks and why is that
theme song so good though that is a
close second but rather why is the PS 5
so huge look at it it's an absolute unit
it's taller than the Series X anyway now
we have an answer
the short answer for why it's so big is
cooling PlayStation vice-president of UX
design Matt LeClair instead quote
thermals this gen is little
supercomputers while the 7 and then
process delivers amazing heat
performance for the power the power is
very extreme
there's also another possible reason a
leaked patent shows a cartridge like
device speculation is that this
cartridge could be fitted with an
external solid-state drive and the whole
thing is then inserted into the PS 5 but
that's still unconfirmed great news
sports fans because Madden NFL 21 is
coming in August and it's got new
features and improvements Madden NFL 21
is coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
August 28th the cover athlete is Ravens
quarterback lamar jackson and the cover
style is getting a redesign instead of
just one picture of him the cover is a
collage of a few different photos as far
as gameplay changes there will be
improved ball carrier mechanics and full
control for running backs and receivers
enhance d-line mechanics to give pass
rushers more options new systems that
allow for more realistic open field
tackling more player controlled
celebrations new on-field camera shots
and improved player awareness on the
field single campaign is
and it's called face of the franchise
rise to fame and it's framed like a
documentary your character starts as a
quarterback in high school then you can
choose to be running back or wide
receiver in college and the NFL
pre-orders are open now and we've got
your pre-order guide on gamespot if you
get the MVP Edition that you can get the
game three days early if you buy Madden
21 on the ps4 or Xbox one before Madden
22 comes out next year you can upgrade
to the PS 5 or series X version for free
so as a result yes Madden 22 was
technically announced today as well
that's your news but we're also still
right in the middle of play for all
while we're raising money for black
lives matter and covin 19 relief efforts
and we've got charity livestreams every
Monday through Friday at 12:00 p.m.
Pacific 3 p.m. Eastern we've got a bunch
of great guests and tomorrow we're
playing Final Fantasy 7 remake with the
voice of Erath and Jake Val Deana joins
us on Thursday and we're also bringing
you the biggest news exclusives
interviews and more for more info check
out the links in the description that's
your safe state for today I'm Shasta you
can find me on twitter at chasity
underscore V or over on GameSpot
universe on YouTube kurz back tomorrow
with more news and I'll see you next
time
[Music]